the only inzone products from Sony we've
all seen are mostly headphones like the
H5 that we have in the office and you
know what it makes sense every other
company out there has a focus on gaming
headphones anyway and honestly there
aren't that many great gaming Centric
earbuds out there until now these inone
butts are for the PS5 and PC people out
there and the whole idea with this you
know is that you get to the office pull
this out remove the dongle that's inside
the case plug into your PC and get to
work and once you get home take out the
dongle again plug into your PS5 or PC
and get some much needed gaming time and
that's pretty much my idea of who I
think this Y 2 be before and the sweet
sweet cherry on top are the drivers in
these that are the same as the XM 5s in
such a small and surprisingly
comfortable package yes and these units
are reminiscent of the WF 1000 xm3s that
came out like I don't know just before
Co started in 2019 kind of similar right
off the bat but there is so much more
going on in the inzone buds Inside the
Box you get a USB e USBC cable
instructions extra ear tips and the main
unit which includes the case the pair of
enzone buts any dongle that switches
between PC and PS5 and mobile I won get
the respects too much they're online
somewhere but the Baseline is that these
run a specially designed 8.4 mm driver
or dynamic driver access that's what
Sony's calling it that's found in the XM
5S do I really need to explain how good
the xm5 sounds it's lightweight you got
12 hours battery on this thing hella low
latency under 30 MS with its dongle
noise cancellation and it comes with
spatial sound that you can use provided
you have a Sony account which you should
and a stack companion app on PC I need
to emphasize this there is no
conventional bluetooth support Bluetooth
is only for phones with Le audio which
are mostly Android phones which then
narrows it down to mostly Sony Experia
phones and also it literally says that
on the box I tried it out with my iPhone
15 Pro and it wasn't the best experience
the dongle pretty much takes over the
phone's volume buttons and you'd have to
Tippy tap the butts to adjust the volume
before we continue this channel is
supported by Brands who help us improve
our content and keep us going so stay
around for this sponsored message here G
culture we've tested plenty of chairs
but secret La gaming chairs remain one
of our favorites whether it's for work
or play they feel great to lean back
against with the ergonomic features
offering support for the whole body from
the head and back to the arms and even
something for your butt this mix of
Forman function helps the Titan Evo 2022
deliver the best seating experience like
no other for more information check out
secretlab.co I mean mobile users aren't
the main targets for Sony in the inzone
series they already have their main line
of amazing headphones and butts these
are for the gamers PC masteries enjoyers
and PS5 Legion s operating the inzone
buds with PS5 is really just plug-and
play attach it to one of the USBC ports
on the outside side and get ready to
game it's that simple you then got to
use the TPT control patterns to control
the noise cancellation options and the
volume and honestly with time you get
used to doing all that one thing to note
is that there are two modes one is for
Bluetooth and one is a USB transceiver
mode and the thing is that if you want
to change the modes you got to hold on
both sides for about 3 to 5 seconds and
it will change modes and they react very
differently of course and obviously
you'll be mostly on the USB transceiver
mode because of the dongle so just keep
that in mind because I initially thought
that I had some issues with mine but
it's just that I was set in different
mode so yeah and one more thing is that
the microphones are synced up to the
controller so when you turn off the
microphone it reflects that on the
controller as well so I think it's
pretty nifty PC Fells on the other hand
it's pretty much the same though with
the addition of the enzone app you get
the customize your EQ get your spatial
audio profile onto the butts and all
that great stuff in there however I did
run into some issues when I was trying
to connect them I had to remove the
dongle here and there put the butts in
and out of the case and back on and even
though it was all connected with the
dongle connected to my PC and my butts
were in and up with the computer's audio
the inzone ad just wouldn't recognize
the dongle but at least the audio was
still going through the butts and I
think that's okay Sony will definitely
release an update and to be fair we
obviously got it early so they'll pick
up on it soon enough in terms of ranking
how much of a hassle it is to work for
the three platforms from least to most
you got the PS5 PC and mobile I wouldn't
recommend it for people that want to get
this solely for mobile gaming there's
still some Grace left if you're planning
to get these for PC gaming because
honestly they work and sound like a
dream I played cyberpunk 2077 on the PS5
with ENC on and I just got sucked into
it using in earbuds over headphones
means you can go for much longer without
feeling the fatigue that comes with the
weight of the headphones and their
clamping Force playing Counter Strike or
even Apex Legends on PC that under 30 MS
latency will save your ass when you hear
that single misstep from the enemy
before you see them and get your guns
ready all right so we are playing Apex
Legends right now and this is how the
audio sounds like from the microphones
of the inzone earbuds coming through my
PC right now and we're going to be
playing a game we're going to be playing
Counter Strike 2 as well and honestly
just seeing how my reactions are like
when put in a real life scenario so
let's have fun with this let's go
time out reloading confirmed
kill
throwing
my so playing cyber punk I am just fully
immersed in the wall because of how
amazing those drivers are from the XM FS
or you know probably inspired by the XM
FS when it comes to Apex and I hope
Counter Strike has the same results
later on I'm able to get the information
I need because of how the earbuds are
especially with the active noise
cancellation it
just silences out any other NB noise
coming from the game and outside of it
oh
boy they got me
hostile
en a come on okay I got up
now okay it's one
guy oh okay there's one guy here
see
okay I just yeah as you can see I I
can't I can figure out where they
are counterterrorist
[Applause]
win that's called muscle memory
baby that's a
here a I could have been three but I did
tag him there is comfortable as these
Samsung Galaxy buds 2 Pros that we
reviewed before which you can check out
here and that says a lot L because with
how they were designed I could really go
the distance of 4 hours and more H my
dual sense controller battery died off
before the butts did just like how Kia
broke before the garden again they're
using the same drivers with the xm5
headphones in a way more ergonomic and
smaller casing than the original wf1000
xm3 so PC peeps out there you might want
to hop on this PS5 owners do I really
have to say anything also I just need to
mention with these butts you can take
advantage of the PS5 Tempest 3D audio
tech so keep that in mind and I want to
talk more about how comfortable these
Butts Are by making space between the
tragus and an trus Hol keeping it
relatively compact minimizing contact
with the ear and most of the device
remains outside of your ear holes and
the result you get with those design
choices Sony has made is that you hardly
feel these earbuds over long periods of
usage it's super lightweight and
combined with the comfortable stock ear
tips that's provided and the drivers
that's on these things you're going to
be in for a treat anyway that's it for
this video If you any questions about
these inzone buds leave them in the
comment section below and if you like
what we do maybe follow us on all of our
socials right here to keep up with the
stuff we put out daily and maybe hit the
like And subscribe buttons it really
helps us out a lot have a great week and
I'll catch youall
[Music]
soon
m